es war nur als Horrorszenario fürs Kino
gedacht der Komplettabsturz der Blackout
der ganz große Systemfehler der der
Realität plötzlich bedrohlich nahe kommt
seit die Bahn in Norddeutschland für ein
paar Stunden komplett lahmgelegt wurde
wer war's ist aktuell gar nicht wichtig
denn wichtig ist dass die Täter uns
gezeigt haben dass wir Herr wundbar sind
und dass wir Dinge anders machen müssen
ich denke wir haben uns grundsätzlich
über kritische Infrastrukturen nicht
genügend Gedanken gemacht das wurde
immer sehr stiefmütterlich behandelt ist
ja auch so ein bisschen langweilig und
es wurde auch nicht genügend Geld
investiert weil man gesagt hat in
unserem eigenen Land sind wir ja sicher
aber sind wir offenbar nicht es brauchte
nur zwei saubere Schnitte in Herne
kappten die Täter am vergangenen Samstag
den leicht erreichbaren Hauptstrang der
zukommunikation und durchtrennten danach
bei Berlin auch noch dass ersatznetz wie
war das möglich die Innenministerin
kündigt ein Umdenken für die kritische
Infrastruktur an und wirkt dennoch los
will ihn auch einmal sagen in dem
Rechtsstaat werden sie nie
hundertprozentige Sicherheit haben so
ehrlich sollten wir uns auch machen
sonst kommen wir in eine
überwachungsstart den niemand möchte
Frau hat recht Infrastruktur in der
Fläche des Landes lässt sich nicht
beschützen das gilt für alle Netze was
wir aber tun können ist diese Netze so
planen und so bauen das selbst bei einem
Sabotageakt oder einem natürlichen
Ausfall sei es ein Bagger oder ein
umfallender Baum den Leitung mitnimmt
dass der Ausfall kurzfristig ist und
lokal begrenzt wie naiv man bisher war
zeigt sich daran dass die Anleitungen
zur bahnsabotage praktisch im Internet
stand denn die Bahn hatte das
rückfallkonzept für den Ausfall des
zugfunks öffentlich ins Netz gestellt
noch zwei Tage nach der Tat war er dort
für jedermann zu finden darin
nachzulesen welcher Ausfall auf bis zu
720 Streckenkilometer wirkt innerhalb
derer der Zugfunk dann gestört wäre
inzwischen ist das Dokument gelöscht man
muss dazu sagen dass wir
Nachrichtendienste die
Sicherheitsbehörden schon seit Jahren
vor diesen Dingen auch gewarnt haben
aber ich will sagen ganz konkret auch
was Russland angeht diese Warnungen sind
verheilt weil sie den politischen
wirtschaftlichen und anderen Interessen
widersprochen haben plötzlich gilt alles
als anschlagsgefährdet Strom Internet
Wasser wie im Film die Pipeline legs als
weltweiter Weckruf die schwedische
Regierung vermutet einen staatlichen
Akteur dahinter die scheidende
Ministerpräsidentin red im ZDF-Interview
sich auf den Ernstfall vorzubereiten sag
ich der Laubmann man braucht immer genug
Wasser ein Radio das keinen Strom
braucht einen Taschenlampe ist wichtig
und Essen für einige Tage denn es kann
zu Stromausfällen kommen und auch andere
Ereignisse sind denkbar die dazu führen
dass man ein paar Tage allein klarkommen
muss
ein großflächiger Stromausfall der
sogenannte Blackout was das für
Deutschland bedeuten würde hat sich der
Bundestag schon 2010 von Risiko
berechnen lassen Ergebnis spätestens am
Ende der ersten Woche wäre eine
Katastrophe zu erwarten mit dem Tod sehr
vieler Menschen doch während man in die
cyberabwehr danach viel investierte
wurde analog gespart so will die
ampelregierung den Etat für
bevölkerungs- und Katastrophenschutz im
kommenden Jahr um 40% kürzen jetzt aber
rückt die kritische Infrastruktur ganz
hoch auf die Agenda jedes wichtige Kabel
soll künftig mit einem zweiten
abgesichert sein Sicherheitslücken
schneller gemeldet und geschlossen
werden aber vor allem wir brauchen klare
Zuständigkeiten man muss wissen wer
trägt in welchem Bereich Verantwortung
wir brauchen eine klare Analyse wo gibt
es besondere Schwachpunkte wo kann man
vielleicht mit gar nicht so viel Geld
relativ stark den Schutz erhöhen das
sogenannte kritis-dachgesetz soll noch
in diesem Jahr in Eckpunkten vorliegen
wenn der Systemfehler nicht schneller
ist